I get this initial joy that I'm very
happy about I haven't proved it but I
also get this fear that I'm about to
completely embarrass myself in front of
the mathematical community by claiming
to approve some well-known result when
actually there'll be some obvious
mistake because I've I put a plus
instead of a minus somewhere so you get
this you for draw an adrenalin rush but
then it's followed pretty quickly by
complete fear that I'm about to trash my
reputation and do something completely
idiotic today you're going to talk about
a conjecture of Dutton Schaffer that was
recently proven by myself and my
collaborator dimitra's Loblaws so
this is like math news is it yeah
exactly
hot off the press so this is a problem
about diaphragm time approximation let's
just take a step back and think about
what diaphragm approximation is in
general so it may be the most simple
numbers we know are just the whole
numbers one two three four and so on
so you slightly more complicated there's
rational numbers which adjust ratios or
fractions of whole numbers so one-third
two-thirds but as well as rational
numbers there's irrational numbers which
can't be expressed as just a ratio of T
whole numbers Oilers number e starts off
as 2.71828 and then goes on how far do
you know that one okay I know it up to
two aid and then I stopped say it's no
coincidence where I draw the dots
similarly PI is another famous
irrational number 3.14159 and these are
numbers where we've proven that you
can't write it as just a ratio of two
whole numbers and in fact there's a
whole zoo of numbers out there and in
many ways most numbers can't be written
as just a ratio of two whole numbers so
most numbers are these complicated
numbers that seem to have some crazy
decimal expansion that probably has no
patterns in it whatsoever and so then
there's a question is to what do we even
really mean by these rational numbers so
I put these dots here really what this
expression is saying is I have lots of
different approximations to the number
pi
which get more market so maybe a first
approximation is that pie is roughly
equal to three and then a second
approximation is pi is approximately
equal to three point one which is 31
over 10 and then a better approximation
is that pi is approximately equal to 314
over 100 3.14 and so on this is really
what we mean by an irrational number
we can't just uniquely define it in a
very easy way typically but we can
define it by the sequence of simple
approximations the sequence gets closer
and closer in on one number pi for
example was historically very important
for engineers to be certain bits of
architecture and they needed to know it
to a certain level of precision and to a
given number position you can just
approximate it by some rational number
good enough to be able to bridge or
something yeah exactly every irrational
number has a decimal expansion like this
and that's one way of understanding them
but sometimes though rather more
efficient ways of writing them as a
ratio rather than just numbers with
denominators 10 or 100 or a thousand or
so so one famous one is that pi is
approximately equal to 22 for seven and
even though maybe 22 over 7 is a much
simpler looking fraction than 314 over
hundreds because the numbers are quite a
lot smaller
pi is actually closer to 22 over 7 that
it is to 314 over 100 and so this is
somehow a very efficient way of
approximating pi and so if you an
engineer or something you wouldn't have
to care about 314 over hundred you could
just use 22 over 7 and that worked much
better it's a very famous theorem of do
Schley that every rational number has a
fairly efficient sequence of
approximations like 22 over 7 that
approximate the number better than you
might expect this is there like a
mathematical name for them these likes
these silver bullets but this would have
set up they're known as the convergence
to the irrational number there's an
algorithm for producing if you give me
your favorite irrational number I can do
some calculations and it can spit out
these convergence which of these very
efficient
summations the number 3 TSP says that
regardless of what irrational number you
choose let's say your favorite rational
numbers some number alpha then you can
find lots of different approximations of
rationals let's call it a over Q and
this is going to be an efficient
approximation in the sense that the
error term in the approximation is at
most 1 over Q squared so regardless of
what the rational number you choose
there's infinitely many different pairs
in Q where you have this efficient
approximation where the arrow is pretty
close by comparison when we just doing a
decimal expansion we would just have an
error term which looks like 1 over the
denominator and so it's not anywhere
near sufficient the whole problem of
define an approximation is variations on
this question if you give me an
irrational number how well can i
approximate it by rational numbers and
how efficiently can i approximate it but
unfortunately this whole area is a zoo
of different complicated impossible
questions we know from 3-phase theorem
that we can approximate PI with an arrow
1 over Q squared so one natural question
is when I do even more efficient
approximations can I get maybe an
approximation that looks like one of Q
cubes so that'd be even better and this
is a well-known open problem we don't
know if you can approximate PI to that
level of efficiency has until now 1 over
Q squared vain the best you could do
yeah for pi I don't think we really know
anything better than 1 over Q squared
for some special rational numbers you
can do better than 1 over Q squared and
to really show you how pathetic we are
and how little we know about these
problems you could consider the number E
+ pi and we don't even know if a plus PI
is rational or not so it could be that a
plus pi is equal to just a over Q for
some whole numbers a and Q it's clearly
not going to be the case but as
mathematicians we have no way of
disproving this that the amazing of
someone found that yeah so it would be
completely crazy and you can check small
numbers so it's got to be the case that
hanky
have to you can prove that they'd have
to have loads and loads of digits if
they possibly were this and kind of it
clearly the case that this can't be the
case but we have no way of proving this
at all
and this is really typical for these
Daffy and Hannah proximation problems
that they're really complicated problems
and subtle problems that we really don't
understand very well at all as
mathematicians and there are some
numbers that can be approximated very
well but almost all numbers you can't
really do much better than one over Q
squared you can do a tiny bit better
than two it shows theorems but do chase
them it's almost as good you can do
Dauphin and Schaefer asked a huge
generalization of this question where
you are only allowed to use specific
denominators q so maybe you choose the
primes or the squares or whatever crazy
subset of the integers that you like and
say the question that definitely fir
asked was if you choose your favorite
sequence of rationals how well can you
approximate these numbers what's a
efficiency of the approximations it was
very much part of their philosophy that
they wanted a super general theorem that
would work for absolutely every possible
choice of denominators so at first sight
this seems crazily ambitious that I've
already said there's these basic
problems like a plus PI and we don't
even know whether they're rational or
not but then suddenly we're asking for
arbitrary approximations of almost
arbitrary equality for arbitrary sets of
integers so it seems like this crazy big
generalization and we know already that
you can have to allow for some small
number of exceptions but then there's an
amazing theorem of castles and then also
Gallagher who showed that you choose
your set of denominators and you choose
what threshold you have for efficiency
and regardless of how you set it up
either almost all numbers can be
approximated using those denominators at
that level of efficiency or almost no
numbers can't be so you have this crazy
simplicity suddenly in this whole world
of complex problems that either almost
everything can be approximated in the
way that you want or almost nothing can
be approximated in the way that you want
regardless of how you choose your
denominators or how you choose your
efficiency of approximations so we know
that you get either everything or
virtually nothing but then the question
is with one of the two cases are we in
and so the Duff and Schaefer conjecture
was saying there should be a simple
criterion as to whether you get almost
everything or almost nothing so we can
write this down you choose your
denominators so let's call them Q 1 Q 2
and so on and then you choose the
tolerable errors so how efficient me you
want to do for each of nominator so
let's call it e 1 e 2 and so on and then
you want to know can you approximate
your rational numbers alpha by
denominators from your favorite set with
the error term of your choice of how
this this is very difficult for an
individual alpha but we know that either
you can approximate almost all of them
or almost none of them and then the duff
and Schaffer conjecture now a theorem is
that there's a simple test for whether
you can get almost all of them almost
not is there an example is this
something you can apply an example to so
this is the slightly frustrating thing
about the theorem that because it's so
general and you always allow an
exception said you can't say for any
individual irrational number whether you
can approximate things but one possible
example is you could choose your
denominators being the squares so 1 4 9
16 and so on and I now have to think
about what the error terms might be one
choice is I could choose one over the
denominator so these are gradually
getting better and better approximations
so this would be 1 over 1 1 over 4 1
over 9 1 over 16 and so on and it's not
too difficult to see with these
acceptable errors that you can
approximate basically every rational
with these error terms so this is not
very ambitious maybe a more ambitious
thing would be to try and do what we did
here and have one over the denominator
square that we're looking at smaller
error terms and so it's more accurate
approximation so I could be more
ambitious and try and do the same
mysterious theorem but where the
denominators
the squares so the outer terms would be
1 over 1 1 hit 4 4 squared 1 over 9
squared and so on and then again there's
a simple test as to whether you can
approximate almost all numbers almost no
numbers and in this case the
dolphin-safe of conjecture now our
theorem says you were being too
ambitious here and so actually almost no
numbers can possibly be approximated at
this level of accuracy with this choice
a set of non-natives
so you plug in your denominators you
plug in your error terms and then
there's a relatively simple thing that
will say either yes you can approximate
virtually everything or no you get
basically nothing at all could I give
you just any arbitrary collection of
denominators could I just say like the
Brady numbers here are the Brady numbers
will it work for pie and a in that and
you'll be able to plug it into your
machine and say sorry Oh yep it's gonna
work yeah exactly so again there's
always got to be a small number of
exceptions because there's the crazy
examples but yeah you choose your
favorite Brady numbers and you say how
will you want to approximate numbers by
Brady numbers and then there's a very
simple test either yeah you can
basically approximate everything or well
know you've been too ambitious
you can basically not approximate
anything at all and there's no in
between ground it's not like you can
approximate 50% of numbers or 30% of
numbers is either 100% of numbers or 0%
of numbers which is kind of the beauty
in this that normally these problems are
all so complicated but then this this
one moment where either you're getting
virtually everything or virtually
nothing and there's a very simple pest
now to tell which 150 cases you in that
was what was really conjectured by
deafening Shaffer they proposed the test
if you're in the field and you
understand these things it's the most
natural test you could possibly have but
the problem was always is this really
the true test that we could prove that
the test worked for lots of very special
sequences of denominators and things so
if you chose the primes then we knew
that it would work the Duff and shaffer
test but we didn't know for completely
arbitrary choices of numbers you know
the Brady numbers
you could have chosen them in such a way
that we wouldn't know whether this was
really delight tests or not or if there
was a subtle other thing that meant that
the dark antifa test wasn't really the
like criterion for whether you would get
almost all numbers almost no other
certain types of denominators that work
better and are more likely to give me
that positive result then other
denominators like you said for Prime's
usually it's going to be pretty good are
there certain numbers that are more
conducive to this than others yeah so
there can be problems when the your
denominators have lots of small prime
factors and so this was really the big
point behind Duff and Schafer's work
that they realized that there was this
subtlety that if you have lots of prime
factors in your denominators you can
rate like the same rational number in
lots of different ways we have the the
rational number 1/3 is equal to 2/6 and
is equal to 3 ninths and you can keep on
writing these different rationals as
being the same thing because you can
cancel out common factors the only way
that things wouldn't behave in the most
obvious way would be if you kept on
hitting the same numbers again and then
again again for precisely this reason
that the numbers which are well
approximated by one third are also well
approximated by numbers with the norm
806 and also were well approximated by
numbers with in honor to 9 because
they're all basically the same numbers
James for this theorem to hold do the
denominators have to have been produced
in some kind of systematic algorithmic
way could I have just pulled 50 numbers
out of you know a bucket and said these
are the denominators or do they have to
be like you know the Fibonacci numbers
or the prime numbers do they have to be
like just selected in some legitimate
way no you can really choose whatever
crazy numbers you like so you have to
have any of them to possibly hope to get
infinitely many approximations or so you
can't have a finite number of numbers in
that denominator category no you so you
need to have an infinite number to
really stand a chance because it's all
asking can you approximate numbers to as
good
accuracies you like so if we now
approximations for pi you just stop with
numbers less than 100 then well you
wouldn't know what the next decimal
place was and so you couldn't tell the
difference between pi in a whole load of
other numbers so you need to have
infinitely many numbers but the whole
point of the theorem is it's a
completely arbitrary collection of
numbers and you can choose whatever you
like you don't have to choose it in some
nice mathematically sensible way you can
just pick keep on picking numbers out of
the Hat in some crazy fashion and
regardless of how you choose them
there's a simple way of telling whether
you get almost all numbers been well
approximated or almost no numbers been
well approximated was this a burning
conjecture in mathematics so I think it
was viewed as one of the more important
problems in metric dyfan time
approximation so metric define time
approximation is when you asking for
these almost all results and this was
somehow the canonical example of a
conjecture and if you can't hope to do
this you can't hope to say more subtle
things about how you can approximate
numbers give me a feel for what the
proof was like was it sort of a one of
these simple elegant ones was a bit of a
monster so I think the basic idea is
quite simple but then there's a whole
load of annoying technicalities that
meant that it turn into a bit more of a
monster but one of the fun things is
that we use some ideas that weren't
standard in the field and so in
particular one way of trying to
understand this situation is that we
ended up drawing lots of graphs so we
would just draw lots of dots where dots
represent denominators and then we would
draw lines between dots when there were
mathematical complications to do with
them and then we stare at these graphs
and by understanding these graphs very
well we were able to understand the
original problem so one of the main
things that we did was to try and
understand the problem using these very
simple ideas of dots and lines which is
way to somehow visualize some of the
complexities of what's going on do you
remember the moment that you and your
collaborator had cracked it like was
there a minute or of the day where it
was like hey I think we've done it or is
it more gradual than that okay so there
was one moment
when I thought okay I think we've done
it there was a lot of work after that to
make sure that actually all the fine
details were to have in the way that I
hoped but yeah there was definitely one
moment was like hang on a moment I think
we can actually do this that there was
one issue that we've been stuck on for
quite a little while and then suddenly
we came up with a way of getting around
that and yeah that's pretty fun moment
so I was at you just sitting in this
room thinking about the problem is a bit
strange because I'd expected this to be
a really tough battle that I was gonna
have to grapple with for quite a long
time and I really wasn't sure if I was
gonna win the fight but then suddenly I
there was a trick that actually managed
to get around the problem so rather than
having to take on the battle that I
thought I was going to have to fight
head-on I could just sidestep the whole
thing and so in some ways it felt a bit
like a cheat that I proven the theorem
that I wanted to prove but the key
difficulty in the proof actually I
didn't have to fight head-on at all we
were both pretty happy as soon as we got
to this stage where we are pretty sure
that everything would work out then
although actually I was at the thing
when I proved these results I get this
initial joy that I'm very happy but I
haven't proved it but I also get this
fear that I'm about to completely
embarrass myself in front of the
mathematical community by claiming to
approve some well-known and so when
actually there'll be some obvious
mistake because I've I put a plus
instead of a minus somewhere so you get
this you fall join our n alone rush but
then it's followed pretty quickly by
complete fear that I'm about to trash my
reputation and do something completely
idiotic how often when you have those
breakthrough moments like that do you
end up finding you have made a mistake
and and you just sort of keep quiet and
how often do you convert them into wow I
was right
okay there's sort of two different
levels of breaking moments there's ones
where I don't really believe it myself
and there's the ones that I really
believe it myself so it's very common in
the day for you for me to be like hang
on this seems to be proven this amazing
result but I'm always a bit skeptical as
to whether I've really done it and those
ones 99 percent at the time they turn
out to be completely and there'll
be some really
stupid thing that I've messed up and you
get up the next day you look at what
I've done I was thinking how did I miss
this I've been a complete idiot here but
then there's the other ones where you
somehow intuitively feel that yeah this
feels right you know I feel like I've
got to grips of the problem and I've
really solved it and okay tough word
fortunately so far all of those that
turn out to actually work out and just
lastly when you have a breakthrough
moment like that like you have that idea
the way to circumvent the problem and
that is that such a big thing that you
couldn't forget it or do you have to
write it down quickly in case you forget
the idea like okay I think I couldn't
forget these things and told that
normally when I've been working on
problem I'm pretty obsessed by it and so
it's sort of coursing through my body
the whole time and in the back of my
mind even when I'm having lunch and
having a shower and things and so I
really have all the bits of the problem
in my head and as soon as I have the
idea for the problem I'm not going to
forget that easily I often want to write
it down to check that it really does
work out the way that I think it works
out but yeah you'll be over my dead body
that I forget in these ideas I think
most recent time where we've seen
someone really write down the conjecture
officially was just over a hundred years
ago by Deponia me AK but he actually
conjectured to rather stronger more
general form of the twin prime
conjecture that's a bit more complicated